[Music]
there it is there it is
there it is guys got a new Prezi in it's
Monday January 23rd and that is hail to
the chief that's the song they play man
probably cop that from the Native
Americans back in the day I wonder if
that burns them a little you know hail
to the chief knowing that uh you know
that honestly probably a lot of whites
took their land and a lot of Europeans
I'm bettin a lot of time it's just
really generalized that White's did it
but I'm betting there were a lot of
Europeans there on horses as well I got
some tea I'm not feeling that that well
I don't know what I got I just got like
uh kind of a head just fluish kind of
thing I think I'm trying to I think I
had this homeless dude right and you
know I respect a homeless bro um you
know of I've lived I've lived in some
shitty places I've never lived I slept
in a ball pit one night actually when I
first got to LA the first couple of
nights I was here a buddy of mine and I
were looking for a place right we're
looking for an apartment so we didn't
have a place to sleep we didn't have a
place to sleep so what we did was at
night we would jump over the fence at
the McDonald's off of Wilshire Boulevard
here in Los Angeles and we would sleep
in the ball pit you know the play the
play area we would sleep in the ball pit
right so the first night we're in there
you know and it's cool it's kind of uh
it was a little cold it was a little
cold but you get under the balls it's
not as bad you know your body heat kind
of builds up and we were wearing a lot
of extra winner
you know attire then the second night
same thing we're in there and during the
day we're checking out seedy places and
you know trying to figure out what we
can get approved for to get a lease the
third night we're in the pit you know we
jump in after they shut down they shot
it 11
get out of there five and uh and we're
talking we're in the ball pit
and all of a sudden there's like an
Asian dude on the slope from the slide
we hear a guy say hey can you guys keep
it down out there there was another guy
sleeping on the on the plastic slide
that came down into the ball pit so I
mean I think it was age and duty sounded
Asian could have been a guy with a lisp
or with you know what else could he have
had maybe a part of his tongue was damn
is just somebody sounded Asian it
sounded like an Asian gentleman so so I
guess I have been a little bit homeless
that's as homeless as I've been but
outside of that I've lived in some real
[ __ ] holes grew up in a [ __ ] hole
but anyway I borrowed a homeless guy was
like you know doing raps and I respect
that you know it's something you know
you got to come up I've never really
heard of we got going from homeless to
you know to UM to pop sensation but but
it could happen and so the dude he gave
me his headphones like listen to this
listen to this hit you know it's got to
be of course is a hit bro I haven't even
heard it you know let me judge that but
anyway he put his head for he gave me
his headphones and I put him in my ears
and that I think was the bad move
because after that I just felt my brain
and in my head and everything I just
felt squirrelly so so I just shouldn't
have borrowed
cinnabar that dude's headphones so
that's just a note for the future you
know don't use you know use your own
headphones don't go don't borrow
homeless guys headphones anyhow its
January 23rd
[Music]
hail to the chief
hail to the chief this chief what have I
been up to man been feeling okay man
some indecisiveness recently we're gonna
get into a couple of things in a minute
and some of the news I'm gonna talk
about a little bit of sensuality give
you guys a little sensual report on you
know some sensual stuff I've been
dealing going through and dealing with
what else we'll talk about we got a
request from a fan via snapchat we have
I promise you guys that talk about some
oral you know different oral sensual
activities that I have when I was
younger and a couple more sounds I got a
few more sounds I just kind of went
through my brain and found some sounds
that I make so that's what's on the
docket Oh what matters feeling
indecisive I had a you know I didn't I
get in this thing where like I'm hungry
but I don't have any food you know and I
have money to get food you know I'm
thankful for that but so I'm at the
grocery store you know finally good you
know give in to my desires of my stomach
and I get over there and they got the
yogurts bro right I'm in a yogurt
section and and I like the dairy section
man I'm a dairy guy you know I'm lactose
intolerant but I'm brave you know I get
out there and those you know I mean
you're out in those forest streets a lot
of times bro if you choose to do dairy
and if your system isn't really you know
isn't you know doesn't have a proper
gradient for dairy you know you can kind
of you kind of can live in those foreign
streets so they got the yogurts dude and
the the yogurts it was aw it was eight
for four dollars now that's a deal but
that's a deal you know and the problem
was I start picking them out and I just
get bit by something that always plays
me as I'm indecisive you know and I know
one of the one of the one of the one of
the cornerstones of a real champion
human and of a good man is that you know
he's decisive and I'm trying to be more
decisive
you know I know that I struggle with it
and I want to do it but you know I want
to make decisions better but they got
eight for four dollars but they got they
got thirty flavors of yogurt you know
like when I was young they had to flip
they had blueberry and they had
strawberry bra you know and then they
also had nothing that was the third
flavor member that you ever accidentally
get the nothing flavor you know like you
would get and you open it up you think
it's blueberry strawberry but it's
nothing brah
it just tastes like a like a like a
bucket of milk just jest stated in your
mouth you know that was really
disheartening when my mom would let us
pick out a yogurt and we got the wrong
one
so anyway I'm standing there it's eight
it's eight from $4.50 a pop you know I'm
I'm in I'm in they hooked me with the
deal they hooked me with the literature
right there on the little thing eight
for four dollars but I can't I mean I
can't like right out of the gate I get
two Vanilla's bruh cuz I do vanilla
yogurts I got two Vanilla's but then the
flavors start getting a little bit
squirrelly they have a key lime pie huh
I'm not right you know I don't think I'm
ready for that so I picked up a copy a
couple of cherries cuz that reminded me
of of when I was young as well cherry
was like a new flavor and everybody went
berserk us for that I copped a blueberry
even though I didn't like it
you know we ate a lot of blueberry
yogurt when I was young and it just made
me you know maybe I had a bad experience
I guess but it just I don't know it just
made me feel it makes me feel poor when
I blueberry yogurt makes me feel a
little bit tender they had lemon bursts
I'm not doing that okay I think that's
for you know it's special type of man
maybe you know might be for a womanís
just got a divorce or something I don't
know but I'm not doing lemon bursts
right so so I got a couple of vanillas I
got the cherry I got the blueberry and
and I'm just sifting through these other
flavors dude and they just started
getting this are that gingerbread I
don't think we need it and I ended up
comping actually a couple of basic lines
because I had lime once but
regular line not the key lime pie but I
kind of left a bad taste in my mouth
maybe you know if I don't know if maybe
I've been smoking cigarettes at the time
or maybe I just been in a bad mood when
I ate it so I copped a couple of limes
but literally I'm standing there I've
been at the thing for probably 15
minutes man picking out you know trying
to get my selection of eight yogurts
uh-huh
so I think what I'm saying here is that
I could never be President
[Music]
unless I get better at picking out
yogurts man so anyway that's where I'm
at I guess I'm feeling kind of
indecisive there was a lot of rain today
one of the Hollywood Hills kind of slid
into the street so you know maybe a
couple of you know probably some wealthy
people you know probably lost some very
expensive pets or something I have no
clue what occurred you know probably
some $30,000 rose bushes you know came
down into the into us plea ons live but
that was going on man that's where I
managed you feel a little bit indecisive
but yeah we got a new president the new
presidents in I thought the inauguration
was cool I've never watched it before I
think I'm just getting older now where
you start to kind of tune into those
things because eventually you get old
and just furious about politics and then
you die you know that's how it kind of
works for most seniors
I thought Melania the the new first lady
looked beautiful man I thought that she
looked nice in that dress or I don't
know if that's called a dress or not but
like this you know light blue smock and
I thought it was cool the little kid man
the kid baron just to be like a kid and
you're standing up there had to be so
bizarre I just kept kind of wondering
what was going through his head like
this even you know realize the Magna the
magnet the size of this event does he
have any idea I thought that was pretty
cool to see the kid and there's one
point there's a video out there if you
haven't seen it where his mom tells him
to do something and he likes makes like
this cat hands at her dude so I'm
looking forward to that guy a little kid
getting in the white house and you know
burning some curtains or who knows what
he's gonna do I mean that guy's gonna go
that kid's gonna go through pervert II
in the white house bro I mean anything
is possible so I'm really intrigued to
see how it shakes down for a little
Baron what else what else is in the news
we have violent weather here the most
rain we've had a lot of bad weather out
in in Georgia people died you know
that's that's heartbreaking man when you
cuz usually a lot of times tornado like
tornadoes are just that kind of they're
like see
real killers for poor people like they
just attack the poor you know I mean I
don't know why people continue to build
their homes in these alleys where these
tornados frequent you know I can
understand you want to give ballsy and
get out there and go toe-to-toe with a
tornado bro I actually had a NATO
experience but I wouldn't i went
toe-to-toe with a nato I'm popping a
couple of ah you hear me chewing this a
couple of what are these melatonin gummy
bears they got little gummies and they
help your brain rest at night because I
got a active brain my brains active
that's what they said when I was a child
a lot of my children reports from
schools had active brain strong heart
got the heart of a lesbian my father
always told me that when I was young I
told me I got the heart of a lesbian
which was I was kind of uh kind of stuck
with me I had an old dad something you
guys don't know my dad was 70 years old
when I was born
my dad was born in 1910 he was uh he was
a missionary from Nicaragua so anyway
what are we talking about let me get
back to what I'm talking about I'm
talking about other tornadoes just going
at poor people and I had an experience I
was working on a farm when I was when I
was just out of college in the summer
times I work on a farm on the Louisiana
Mississippi border and that was right
off of a Faraday in Vidalia Louisiana
and that's where Jerry Lee Lewis is from
right around there so I'd be over there
in a I was a farmhand do it I would do
whatever you know drive tractors plant
clean paint odds and ends man that's
what my deal was did we get out there I
had a knife had a gun in the trunk we'd
get out there in the morning and we'd
get out there early 7:30 and we worked
till 7:00 or 6:30 we worked it was a
day's work man
we were I was a man I was a man I was a
man and it felt good man it felt good to
come home and I wouldn't even think I
couldn't even think about anything I was
so tired I would just fall asleep I
would eat with the family they put me up
and and then I would fall asleep and
then I would wake up cracking dawn when
we go again that was it and you you
worked as much as the weather permitted
so you could work twelve thirteen days
in a row sometimes anyhow so one day I'm
I'm working at the farmhouse I'm I don't
know what I'm doing cleaning and her
baby painting and had this other
gentleman that was working with me he
was thick I mean this boy was coming in
he might be deceased now he was you know
that size the kind of size where when
you meet him you you get a good look at
him cuz you know that you're not gonna a
few years later you probably won't get
to look at them again because you know
they're gonna head on back to whatever
back to the spiritual realm because of
their size you know and this guy was
just thick and just always just sweating
out of his neck and his face and just a
sweet man dude he was a sweet man
bro anyway we're working together and
they've been bad weather coming through
and then a tornado report comes up and
it says that there's a tornado right in
our area so we go outside and you can
literally see this tornado
you know maybe 2,000 yards away or a
couple miles I don't know how many yards
2,000 yards this I mean it I know it's
2,000 but it's I have no clue how far
that is I made that up I mean I didn't
you know what I'm saying dude I'm
guessing I'm guessing so we're like we
know we got to hide in a ditch do that's
what you always heard right I think
anyway I mean hell that could be for
anything but for some reason I just
remember that I'm like I'm like bro we
got a hot in this we got a hot in this
ditch so we run across and we and I get
into a ditch too right well this guy and
it's a ditch bro it's like I mean it's
probably three acres long this ditch
it's a little irrigation canal this too
gets in the ditch on top of me
on top of me brush him now I got this
guy 307 pounds on my back laying in this
ditch I mean I'm heavily protected now
from this storm but just the ignorance
really going through that man's skull at
that time and he wouldn't pick another
spot in the ditch to be I mean it's kind
of sacrificial I guess he would get on
top of me like that
it didn't feel homoerotic I I couldn't
feel any of his waist touching me it
just felt like all just Bob just
basically just a breath of stomach and
chest torso meat just uh anyway so that
was just kind of a storm experience man
I had to hole up in this ditch with this
gentleman and uh and yeah the story you
know the tornado came close it didn't
damage the stuff in the area but we were
fine and and that was that so you know I
don't really have any you know if
there's a tornado coming I don't know
what do you do you know what do you do I
guess you get in the ditch that's that's
what I'm I guess that's the advice if
you got a tornado come and get in the
ditch and if you're poor you know just
know that these tornadoes are proper I
mean statistically they were looking for
you you know I don't know if Mother
Nature's just a killer and that's how
she chooses to just get the poor but but
it seems it seems to be enough evidence
there where that's the some validity to
that what else man I will I'll tell you
this dude yeah Trump is in office I got
a new who got a new president I think
change is always exciting I think you
know it's interesting a few years ago I
kind of hated for a long time I've kind
of felt like like my generation nothing
ever happened in our environment that
made us wake up in the morning with any
feelings or any vigor or any you know
like our parents had you know the world
I mean our grandparents had like Vietnam
and some of our parents had Vietnam or
World War one there was a lot of World
War two
obviously you know I'm not a big war
buff but uh but but they like you know
they got up and they had a feeling in
their heart like they had a cause or
they had like you know I stand for this
or like you know when they had all the
Woodstock and the you know like people
were like I you know I you know our
civil rights like people would wake up
with a beat in their heart for like a
reason to be alive and I feel like I've
grown up in this generation or you just
wake up like all right you know I'm up
you know and maybe that just could have
been some of my own
lackadaisical nough speaking up with
some fervor you know they realized that
you know their government probably isn't
gonna help them out very much and that
they that we have to do it ourselves I
don't care what you know if you're
democrat or republican or who you
support but but I feel like that's kind
of cool it's pretty interesting to wake
up and have a just a sense of purpose
when it comes to a bigger realm of
something bigger than ourselves not or
not just ourselves like you know I don't
you know it's like now we wake up with
some fervor and I think that's good so
that's one thing that I that I feel like
is good you know that that's exciting
that you wake up with some [ __ ] dick
in your balls you know with some [ __ ]
extra couch juice in your curtains and
you know what I'm saying ladies like you
just yeah you got a little freaking
spittle in you Gretl you know and so I
think that's exciting man I think it's
always good when when inspiration and I
think change does that any kind of
change if you're you know like just
anything get you up get you up in the
morning and get you fired up that's
that's what's going on they got the new
president they had the March there's a
million women March or I'm not sure how
many women it was a lot of women you
know and that's it was pretty powerful
to see I think a lot of the photos and
stuff because my mother was a
hard-working woman you know and and you
know she delivered newspapers since I
was born
and she would deliver baked goods
regionally on the weekend
no she tried to keep herself a welfare
and you know we would get some food from
the church and stuff like that but so I
think that was inspiring to see these
women you know you know getting together
and and just creating a bond there
sometimes I think feminism it just turns
into like a hate man thing and that's
kind of scary you know cuz men we're
just doing the best we can we don't
[ __ ] know you think we know what's
going on no we're doing the best we can
you know I mean look at us we don't we
don't know we don't know I was thinking
that there's got to be some stark
husbands out there who were praying for
an Isis attack on DC like hoping to get
rid of their wives you know I'm sure
there was a couple of dudes somewhere
thinking like you know better give Janet
a big hug this could there's a great
movie called get on the bus if you've
never seen it was about the Million Man
March and I think it was for when Martin
Luther King was speaking it's pretty
cool man Charles s Dutton's in it but
yet homeless do mana barda's headphones
and I think and dude the rap was
horrible it wasn't even a rap I don't
think it was his song just felt taken
advantage of which makes you think about
Ronald Reagan because Reagan let all the
Reagan next time we when I see homeless
dudes when I see people struggling out
on the street those are Reagan's boys
that's what I call him Reagan's boys
because if you look back they had a law
that was passed in the 60s that provided
like a lot of assistance and special
care for mental health people
well when Reagan was in office the law
got repealed and all of a sudden all the
money was going towards helping people
that were you know just straight up just
a bunch of frickin Seoul Wizards out
there you know they they were out on the
street and a lot of them are still out
there a lot of them have been mating
with other homeless people and making
you know other people that are out there
and that have
tough time in troubled and and that's
Reagan bruh that's Reagan everybody you
know Reagan takes a nice picture he's
got a nice hair
I respect all that decent actor but
Reagan when you see some people are out
there schizophrenic and really
struggling and those are Reagan's boys
man so you know I don't know if Nancy
Reagan still alive but you could
probably tweet at her about it oh man
what else dude what else man had some
adult sex bro you know had some adult
sex and it was it was cool you know it
was cool I think I got a you know make
sure that when I am getting sexually
involved and I'm you know making sure
it's like for something poignant you
know it's for a real relationship or and
in that sort of vein because I'll say
this dude if you stay out there you're
just ding-a-ling in every you know piece
of slick canal that pops up you're it's
not going to help your heart you know
and and I know I'm almost preaching to
the choir so maybe I had a moment fit a
weakness or something I don't know you
know at the same time you trying to be a
man and you know uh this girl's cool
she's neat chick and but I do realize
that uh you know my triceps aren't what
they used to be that's for sure off
really just felt kind of meek just meek
in the triceps you know so that really
kind of hurt my feelings a little bit
got in my head and one of my hips was
clicking I mean just Morse code and the
whole time so that's you know in this
girl's a little younger than me and so
that's that's just I don't know if
that's a turn-off is that a turn-off if
you're a younger girl if any younger
women are listening to this or young men
who you know who prefer to be with men
if you're having sex with a man and he's
older than you and his hip clicks or his
bones are clicking and I already have a
weak neck I've always had a weak neck
never never anything I feared more than
a headlock if there was
there was one buddy I had grown if that
was always head locking people and man I
couldn't be friends with him after a
while just out of the fear just I
couldn't I don't think I'm I don't think
I could go through a head lock a good
head lock I couldn't go through it but
uh but if there's any young ladies out
there who you know who do sex with older
you know with more adult men is that a
turn-off is that do you notice that like
if a man's kind of you know his bones
are click and or something if you guys
are being sensual anyway let me know let
me know if you know sober sex man that's
sober sex that's for children I feel
like sober sex is for children do when
you're young you can be sober to have
sex bro it's awesome you don't you know
you don't notice all your own
deficiencies or inconsistencies you
don't notice like your ashy skin or you
know that you need moisturizer on your
ass or you don't notice you know you got
a you you just don't notice all your
faults but when you get out there as an
adult you're doing sober sex man this
all your senses are so heightened
they're active you know you're just
things are getting out of sorts it's
just so anyway if there's any children
out there do sex when you're you know
sober sex is for children that's that's
when you do it you know get out there
and you know get eggs moist out there
but uh but do it when you're young you
know because when you get older it's
just it's not the same it's not the same
it's not the same but yeah man took this
young lady out borrow a little shellfish
bra they got this place around the
corner and they do a nice little clam
dinner you know to get you a big dish of
clams and you you know you kind of sit
there you can teamwork a little bit and
you know and that's really I feel like
always been the way to a girl's heart
maybe throw some shellfish in a lady and
unless they're allergic if they're
allergic that turn red so you know
that's a that's a stop that's a no-go
shut it down for the night bro when you
throw shellfish and a lady bro you
almost have to hide your dick
because they come out you know their
libido really strikes up even some of
that seaweed brought you warm it up that
hot kale bra you feel a brought up with
hot kale Sun you ready you're gonna have
to exercise some pee control baby you
know what I'm saying yeah bleep look
that's a hot clams and a girl dog you
better have some [ __ ] control ready
bruh and I hate to use the P word man I
know a lot of ladies don't like that you
know but that's what's up man that's so
yeah man got the girl you know we had a
nice time sweet gal you know she works
at actually met her at a yah and uh one
of those uh not a eatin Gois hidden
what's that gas station I think it's hit
and run or eating eat and go hit and run
no hit and run I think as an accident
it's uh eat and run she work at a gas
station again inside not outside she's
not pumping the gas you know she's not
really kind of an outdoors woman she's
more of an indoor service center she
works in the service center at a gas
station dealing with you know people
want to pay for the gas get coffee
snacks and different indoor elements
that she's vending in there but nice
girl man I met her a couple times when I
was getting a tank and then you know we
warm to each other and uh next thing you
know we went on a second date that we
went on you know and um she gots nice
hair and just really she's not the
brightest I don't think really uh she's
not dumb she just isn't when it comes to
knowledge she just it's not really her
strong suit I would say you know but
anyway so we got sensual you know and
now I just got to monitor my feelings
because when I was younger if I would
get sensual with the woman you know get
sexual do sexual activity do some adult
sex a lot of times I would just kind of
you know hide from them or you know
we're not communicate but now we're
trying to communicate clearly exactly
what my feelings are
and that's tough to do man you know
living life on life's terms man it's
tough to do so just trying to be an
adult about the scenario so you know
keep me a thoughts about that if you can
because I'm gonna try to be honest with
this girl and I can always use support
when it comes to that I feel like what
else dude let's get into a little bit
more let's let's cover a little more
sensuality I'll talk about [ __ ] on
the past thing oral sex so I'll tell you
about this when I was young when I was a
younger man I was a child really I was
just a middle aged child and they had
one of my first girlfriends now they had
a girl in our school who had a who done
some [ __ ]
you know and that was the rumor anyway
and you know once a girl once you once
that rumor hits the air it's you know
when I was young anyway it was you know
the girls were like all shaming her but
all the dudes were like you know Tanya's
gonna badmouth booboo so um so anyhow
she liked me man she liked me and this
was like the first girl or maybe the
second girl that ever liked me I dated
another girl that really was like a
young man almost she had real short
short hair and whenever we would hug
kids would yell out the bus and call us
uh they would call us [ __ ] honest it was
call us homosexuals even though she was
and I would yell back this is a girl
because I wanted to stand up for her but
uh but that still kind of hurts my
feelings because she was a sweet girl
real smart and grow up to be beautiful
but at the time she was you know going
through poverty and so as I am you know
just people changing you can morph into
like I'm the other sex for a couple of
after you know friend do you do in
pervert II you'll meet somebody during
the afternoon morning they look fine the
afternoon their neck is an inch longer
you know they hit like a feminine speed
bump and their perverted shirt and
they're pretty trail and yeah so you
don't know but anyway she and I were
going through pervy around the same time
and man our lines were fired up every
day and we would touch hands and I just
[ __ ] legs would get straight that's
held to say erect I was at that time
just god I couldn't even turn my neck
the blood was just so tight I couldn't
even turn my weak weak little neck
anyhow so anyway this other girl you
know there was rumor that she'd uh done
some [ __ ] so I'm fired up
you know cuz she liked me you know and
she was cute and she was funny and uh
and we went there was a party or
something and she and I were gonna make
out bruh you know and so this was my big
opportunity you know I was a young man
and I was just coming in and my feelings
and my nipples were hard one of my
nipples stayed hard for do probably
seven or eight years bro my left nipple
I remember oh it was just so sensitive
you know it was just just a tender just
little it was just like a little just a
little [ __ ] mole of sensuality at the
tip of my little you know chest little
boy a little just boy breast and anyhow
so we supposed to meet in at this party
she and I were gonna meet off in the
woods and we're gonna get do some
[ __ ] you know I was gonna you know be
the recipient of this you know novel new
practice really as far as I was
concerned because it was new and in my
sight Geist of thought or zeitgeist of
life you know nobody was getting this
this was hot activity man and uh and so
we started you know kind of kissing a
little bit and I was nervous dude I was
so nervous I couldn't have I didn't have
any feelings in my body
and so she was I kind of getting my junk
out and a mom saw stated somebody's mom
came up and saw us and I just felt so
ashamed bro oh dude this mom walked up
and saw us right dude and there was like
a pine tree right there and I went and
hid behind the pine tree like there was
no other like there was it was so
obvious and then and the moms like she
knew me she's like do and I just
pretended like I wasn't
err bro and I was literally nine feet
away from him behind this pine tree and
she like walked over a few feet and at a
different angle and she could obviously
see me and anyhow that kind of ended the
relationship with the young lady you
know do it was just too much it was just
I don't know I was just nervous and
there was just brought a lot of
attention to you you know and you could
be the future recipient of the first
blow job out of all your friends it's
just all people are asking you about is
this and this and this and you know
about your you know your just how you
feeling today and making sure you eat an
extra lunch you know you gotta gear up
and you know make sure you you know you
know they're giving off like idiot kids
giving you like it Matt don't masturbate
you got a masturbate like just crazy
advice and just whatever dude and eating
different foods you know man you got a
you know you got to drink more water you
know you got to make sure your dicks
right you know so I was doing all kinds
of crazy stuff man I remember barn some
my mom's lotion and putting that around
my crotch and every I mean I was you
know I was just a young guys going
through it so that was just kind of like
at my first oral experience do it didn't
go well and I think I carried a lot of
shame from that because I was just a lot
of embarrassment you know and and uh and
then the girl and I ended up breaking up
and I think I was kind of bummed cuz she
was really a really cool chick and who
knows if she'd ever given a [ __ ]
before but but anyway has my early
[ __ ] story but yeah man I just had oh
I got a peach yogurt
I got a peach yogurt as well because
they got these fruit bits in it and
that's good stuff so I got that peach as
well um I want to I want to get to a
question from somebody I'm tired man
it's late but on snapchat the Blessed
asked me the BL est asked me what's my
favorite road comedy story and I'm gonna
tell you this story this this is a story
that was told to me but it's the best
story that I've ever heard so a comedian
told me he was performing one time in
the Midwest somewhere
and after the show this hot chick comes
up to him right off the stage and starts
flirting with them all over him and he
was like a moderate looking dude you
know I'm an 8 I know I'm an 8 I'm a
healthy eight but long as I take care of
my teeth I'm an eight I'm cool with
where I'm at you know my jumping in
conclusions but this guy he told me he's
like this hot chick and he says she was
out of it she was out of my league
that's what he said she was all over me
all over me so you know the play starts
to shut down we have a couple of
cocktails she and I are both liquored up
and I'm like well why don't you come
back to my hotel and she's like well why
don't you come with me to my place and
the next day he had to fly out the next
day at like noon so he's like ah you
know I don't know where it is and I
think it was in Cincinnati and is I
gotta already don't know kind of where I
am and I don't know if that's the best
idea and he said the girl got kind of
upset but then she came back to his
hotel with him anyway so they start kind
of making out in his room and this girl
was like one of those crazy girls that
like starts biting you you ever get that
girl like you're just trying to kiss and
she's like trying to bite you all
sexually but like you know like she'll
like bite you on your chin and she bites
you too hard and then you're pissed off
and you're you know you're missing a
little bit of skin or someone your cheek
and you're like what the [ __ ] like then
this is not joy for anyone it's not joy
for anyone but anyway so he said she was
like that she was all over him and
biting him and just kind of pulling his
hair and he didn't have much hair and
now he doesn't have really any hair at
all so I wonder if that kind of
resonates with him a little bit when he
thinks back but but anyway she kept
saying let's go back to my place let's
go back to my place I've got drugs I've
got pills you know she kept saying uh
that her dad was a doctor and she's got
pills and all this stuff and my buddy
started to get freaked out he was like
it was at the point where she was so hot
that I kept keeping her around and I
kept getting bit but it was scary it was
scary so finally he's like look you got
to go and when he said that she like
through a phone book or something in his
room that's when they had fun this is
when they have phone books and a phone
book dangerous [ __ ] instrument thank
God we evolved to two
just like online yellow pages or white
pages cuz that thing probably a lot of
spouses and you know weak males have
lost their their life to a phone book I
bet but anyhow he said that she threw
the phone book at him started throwing
[ __ ] in his room at him so he kicked her
out well
the feature act the guy who was opening
up for him on the road a younger dude
was right down the hall right and he
heard the commotion or whatever so he
had come to his door and while the chick
is leaving she sees him and she'd seen
him on stage earlier before too cuz she
was at the show where she met the
headliner so she starts flirting with
this guy well he doesn't really know
what has occurred he just knows that
this hot chick is all of a sudden is all
over him this young dude and she's like
you should come with me and so of course
the young Dubrow you know his nuts are
straight-up whispering in his ears let's
go so he left he left out with her they
took a taxi or whatever about 40 minutes
and they get out to this house and like
off this like kind of a little bit of a
Shh not shady area but like a wooded
area and she takes him inside and they
started hooking up in this room and
she's like do you want me to is it okay
if I handcuff you and he's like sure
yeah that's cool you know he's like all
fired up so this chick like handcuffs
him and she'd taken some pills or
something right when they got there and
they're all [ __ ] up
well she handcuffs him starts giving him
a blow job and then she passes out like
unconscious like in his lap like
unconscious dude which has got to be I
mean I can't even imagine and he's
handcuffed at this house he doesn't he
doesn't know this girl really and the
door to the room is open and then he
sees headlights flash across the walls
like a car turning into the driveway the
driveway right so this dude's losing his
mind but probably
just coming in his brain but not like
real sweet seed probably just
straight-up scare and fear just juice
just flowing out of his his cerebellum
stem into his brain right and then he
hears the front door open like with keys
and a man a grown man walks past the
room peeks in sees him sees the girl
walks into the kitchen he can hear the
guy in the kitchen here's the guy do
some stuff then the guy comes in picks
the girl up is a man about in his 50s
picks the girl up takes her out of the
room and the whole time I buddies like a
pot you know or not my buddy but this
guy's the feature this guy who's there
who's chained up into the bed is like
apologizing and the old dudes not
talking to him so he's like scared out
of his mind and they didn't have cell
phones it's for they had cell phones so
he's like freaking out there's nothing
he can do the dude comes back in he's
like don't make a word don't make a
sound don't say a thing and he sits on
the bed next to the guy and he's like if
I ever see with my daughter again it's
not gonna end well for you and the dude
is like scared and squirrelly and
everything and then the guy gives the
young dude a [ __ ] man and he tells
him like if he doesn't go along with it
that you know I don't know maybe bad
things are gonna happen or whatever but
he gives the dude a [ __ ] bruh like
with a face and a penis dude and that's
the and then so the guy finishes or
whatever the day then goes into the
kitchen and like apparently that made
himself like a sandwich or something I
guess the kid said he could hear the dad
and they're making a sandwich and not
the kid the guy's not a kid he's
probably in his early 20s but then the
dad comes back in unlocks him tells him
if he ever sees him with his daughter
again
that uh that it's that things are gonna
be even worse and then just kicks him
out of the house so then you got this
young dude walking in the middle of
nowhere
no phone gets to a pay phone calls the
headliner
the dude who would kick the girl out of
his room earlier calls her and calls him
and says man you got to come pick me up
like this is where I am and the
headliner came and picked him up and
when when the guy got back in his car
that's the story that he told him he
told him what happened and that and
that's the story that that headliner
told me and that's the best Road story
that I've ever heard I mean it's it's
not great obviously because you know
there's a lot of crime in there there's
there's sexual you know deviancy there's
you know meaning I guess got orally you
know raped or attacked you know it's not
right but it's [ __ ] wild bro you know
what I'm saying dude that's a crazy
story and I can't imagine that this
headliner could make that up I mean it's
just too intense man it's just too
intense bro so the blessèd that's the
craziest story I ever heard I know about
this this pot has had a lot of profanity
and stuff in it man and I'm sorry bro
but I'm tired you know I'm tired and
when my brain gets weak sometimes it
resorts to verbal you know it just wants
to be naughty it just wants to be
naughty he won't he he gots a naughty
brain he got to naughty brain but yeah
I'm gonna break down real quick maybe
just to run through a quick recap I got
to eat yogurts you know so I'm Square
there I thought Melania looked good
thoughts and prayers to the people in
Georgia and Mississippi they were
affected by the tornadoes a lot of death
over there I got to get my triceps in
order because you know this and I got to
check on this click and hip you know
because uh because it's just you losing
points they're sexually I think if any
younger girls or girls not young girls
you know of age adult women and have any
thoughts on that let me know or yeah
women have you know or if you're married
and your husband is bodies clicking and
stuff during sex how do you do do you
acknowledge that you let that pass
man if there's something you do if
there's like a silencer or something you
can put on like you wear a brace on your
knee or something or you know wear like
a thick couch remember around your waist
to kind of hide some of the click or
muffle it let me know if you see to
homeless people making out do what I do
bro call the cops bro every time call
the cops and the ladies seem like well
what's the crime and I'm like if they if
they have sex and have a child they're
gonna make on immediately that child is
homeless immediately and I don't think
that you know outdoor people and people
that are having trouble don't deserve
the best but I don't know if that's the
best way to go about it so what else man
let me just give you a I'll give you an
update on how I'm feelin bruh I'm
feeling I've been feeling a little down
in the dumps honest - this past weekend
so it's kind of a bummer you know I feel
a little bit sick from that dude's uh
headphones but yeah my spirits just
aren't super up so I'm hoping that
tomorrow you know will be I mean
obviously tomorrow's a new day and i'ma
start off with you know for maybe a
little bit like prayer maybe some
meditation I'm still stuck on my no
masturbation policy so that's going
strong you know and I guess there are
some positives and I just gotta focus on
that but sometimes it's not easy you
know sometimes it's not easy to keep you
know it's just life stuff and you
sometimes don't even know what it is man
you know like I've suffered from
depression alot of idiots you don't know
what it is but could be anything you
know you know it could be anything
so but that's a little bit of what's
going on with me I feel like we've been
going for a long time so I'm gonna
postpone yeah I'm gonna postpone those
oral sounds until next week because
we've already talked enough about
sexuality here today I feel like and and
that sort of thing but I got another
great story about from my youth about
oral sex but I'll tell that another time
but yeah if you have any thoughts on the
on the on the episode or on the podcast
or anything just let me know you know
because I'm trying to do my best I don't
know what I'm supposed to be doing I'm
literally just sitting up in my
apartment just talking into a recorder
in the middle of the night so it's I
mean if this same weird I don't know
what it is but everything is so but I do
appreciate you guys listening to me I
feel a little bit better than when I
started I almost kind of feel like I had
somebody to talk to a little bit so
maybe that's bizarre but I don't know
everything's bizarre but uh but take
care of yourself why don't you do that
huh
be good to yourself this week you know
you owe it to yourself to try and be
good to yourself you know take some
contrary actions if you're not feeling
good try something different you know if
you got somebody to love tell them you
love and bro if you got a mother call
him tell him you love him it's the only
mother you ever ever gonna have man
it's the only one you ever gonna have
bro I don't care how much you hate her
give her a buzz listen to her for an
extra 10 minutes did I call him on the
other day I don't even know what the
[ __ ] she was talking about dude and most
of the time I don't but at this age even
though we you know had odds at a lot of
time in our life I just listened you
know I just listened I just listened am
I saying that I'm a good person because
of that I'm just saying that uh that I
know that one day I'll look back and
probably regret that I didn't so anyhow
yeah sorry if I'm kind of dour you know
I'm just being however I can be but
congrats to the Atlanta Falcons fans
Congrats to the New England Patriots
fans man Bill Belichick he's good he's
good Pittsburgh didn't show up
they just didn't show up but [ __ ] the
Saints man I love the Saints but I just
cannot deal with Sean Payton as the
coach got to go anyhow that's enough
Sports Talk I'm actually gonna look on
some stuff online I can strengthen my
neck a little bit
I bought this neck weight thing a while
back it's like this hula hoop for your
neck but it's it seemed more dangerous I
felt like after a while then then
actually beneficial but we'll see we'll
see man but this is January 23rd I hope
you have a great week and again any
constructive criticism I know this this
episode got long I'll try to make it
shorter in the future you know I'm just
know what I'm doing but take care of
yourself I got some dates coming up I'll
be in Baltimore in in February I know
and yeah and February I'll be in
Baltimore there's a chance I could come
to Jacksonville all should know that
tomorrow and I'll be in Virginia Beach
this coming weekend actually this
weekend and I'll be in Chicago the
following weekend February 2nd through
4th out in Schaumburg but we got a lot
of cool dates coming up this year and I
appreciate you guys being here this is
this past weekend man have a great have
a great day huh take care of yourself
huh all right that's it
that's it boy so weird that we do this
in America but that's America man or a
weird place I think we're starting to
recognize that I think everybody's
starting to recognize that but I'm happy
to live here man I feel just blessed to
be in this country the fact that we can
even discuss how people feel I remember
going to Cuba once and uh and people
would run up to the windows and they
would tell us like if they were
prisoners but I was an American I was
just drinking in their streets and being
a dumb American but I do remember that
so we're pretty blessed man I am we all
are
do we recognize it I hope so I don't
know I don't know I'm talking about to
the [ __ ] homeless guy he's got a
carry my own headphones with me from now
on
I just shouldn't have listened I should
know listened I knew I shouldn't I just
I hit I knew it was gonna be a hit there
was zero chance of it being a hit dude
but part of me once you know my inner
loop Perlman wants to just wants to you
know I don't know what about whatever
man
you guys be good huh hail to the chief'
you're the chief you were the chief
whoever you are hail to yourself huh be
good